i hate intros how not summoned to demon
lord season one
episode one we kick things off with the
main character takama sakamoto who has
the extremely original backstory of
being a shot in gamer i'm sure the
writers have good reason for giving him
this backstory and not just because it
resonates so much with all of you nerds
he plays an online mmo that's super
popular
called cross reverie apparently he's
been on that grind live for a while
because he is the most powerful player
on the server with his character named
diablo
boom he gets teleported in game as his
character this is where we meet the elf
with two
massive personalities named shira al
greenwood who is also the one claiming
that she summoned him
joining her is the cute loli rem galileo
and i'm sure you guys are one step ahead
of me but you should be aware that there
is only one true rem so when you hear
people talking about rem they're not
referring to this [ __ ] this is walmart
rem
and the writer should be ashamed of
tainting this sacred name because she's
a lolly it's my duty
as an outstanding citizen of the law to
find out if she's legal for you guys so
i did the research and
you hate to see it the writer's letting
us down once again by not making her
some sort of weird demi human with a
couple hundred years behind her but you
know bright side is you're gonna get
your money's worth out of your yearly
vpn subscription so
just be happy about that i like how most
of the shows do the summoning by like a
powerful nation or a group of sorcerers
but instead these guys are like [ __ ] it
we'll just use a girl with a huge rack
and classic anime cat girl now i for one
am sure that the writers have good
reason for giving diablo these
companions it's not because it resonates
so much with you nerds no
it's more complex than that it's not
just them projecting your guys's weird
fetishes on paper no
it's an abstract web of complex ideas
reflected through their work
showing definitive proof that they have
mastered the art of storytelling don't
try and take away from that because
people fat to it don't
back to the story the two thought it
would be a good idea to use an
enslavement ritual on their new summon
which backfires because he has a ring
that reflects
all magic devs thought that item through
which of course reflects the ritual back
onto them so now they belong to him nice
this is more than he signed up for but
what a drag the three of them have to
stick together until they can find a way
to dispel the enslavement so they all
head to the border city of
ultra once at the end we meet a new
character in celestine baudelaire who
was the head of this town's mages
association
she had come looking for rem so
everybody has to awkwardly explain that
they botched a ritual and now she's kind
of a slave
she seems oddly okay with it like on
mondays but one of her bodyguards named
golic
is a huge dick and doesn't like diablo's
attitude but nobody cares what he thinks
because he's a side character so he gets
put in his place
celestine is there to try and convince
rem to go back with her to the mages
association headquarters but rem refuses
saying that she can take care of herself
and on that note celestine excuses
herself and tells him that she will look
into breaking the enslavement for them
things take an interesting turn when
diablo takes rem to force her to tell
him what kind of trouble she's in i'm
sure
all of you guys fondly remembered this
rapey scene with a 14 year old girl but
hey if you don't this is the gist the
soul of the demon lord krebs golem is
sealed away within her body and
apparently it's hereditary so her mom
houses the demon lord also
krabs gollum is the most powerful boss
in cross reverie and rem's main goal is
to defeat her and extinguish her soul
if she doesn't succeed then after she
dies krep's golem will be released
diablo agrees to help her out and find a
way to extract and defeat the demon lord
some of you probably know one might be
wondering why i bothered doing graphics
and a proper intro for a character like
golic well it's because the [ __ ] had
wanted to show up at the end of the
episode so that we could get our first
fight sequence
he brings the squad summons a level 30
lizard blizzard gets killed and then we
learn that diablo is level 150
episode two start the episode off with a
nice grope scene just like it should be
and then diablo learns from the girls
that there is a divide between the
humans and the demi humans in this world
and also that
rem is a level 40 summoner everyone then
heads to the adventurer guild to
register
and get quests for money well there they
use a magic mirror to assess that shira
is a level 30 summoner when they try to
find out diablo's level with the mirror
there's a strange
wave prompting the new character sylvie
the guild master of the adventurer's
guild to come
and investigate turns out he's too
strong to be measured and silvie is
hesitant to allow him to join because
they're never going to have work
appropriate for his level
he doesn't care though and joins anyways
so she gives them their first quest
they head out to defeat a medara snake
in the man eating woods and retrieve its
eyes for experiments that the mages
association are conducting
while heading there diablo also learns
that there's no teleporting in this
world so it differs from cross reverie
when they arrive
shira can sense that somebody is nearby
suspecting that the quest was a trap
diablo launches an attack at the
concealed party they are revealed to be
elves like shira
and being led by a new character celsior
all of them had come to rescue shira who
apparently
is a noble princess in the kingdom of
greenwood diablo speculates that the
quest was a setup by the mages
association because golic holds a grudge
against him jira doesn't want to return
home because she's going to be forced to
marry and bear children with somebody
that she doesn't love
diablo also realizes that nobody has
been fighting in this world like in the
game which has made
all of the people living there such low
levels compared to him phil's launch
attacks against diablo to take shira
back by force they do
zero damage so he uses a nice spell to
freeze everything nearby they start to
panic
garlic is then revealed to be behind
everything and he runs off like a little
[ __ ] why do they just let antagonists
run off in every animated
your level 150 just run up a bit karate
chop and one time he'll blow up and
you're done with that they'll stay
behind to try and convince shira to go
home with them but she reiterates that
she's still not going back the fight
didn't really change anything so
everybody parts ways
wrap things up with another groping
scene and transition into
episode three everybody meets up with
sylvia again because she has another
quest specifically for diablo this time
the quest is coming directly from
celestine so at least they know that
it's not another trap ram doesn't really
like the idea of working for celestine
because she feels like celestine is
trying to indirectly help her out so she
decides to stay behind in the city while
diablo
and shiro go handle it they are tasked
with bringing items to the bridge of
uluk diablo is apparently starting to
get a reputation so he is approached by
a new character
an emile bitchelberger [ __ ] burger is
said to be the strongest warrior in the
adventurer's guild sitting
at a whopping level 50 and thinks that
ram and shira were enslaved by diablo
being the self-proclaimed simp to all
women he tries to set them free through
a duel
obviously it's one-sided but the girls
do put a stop to it before anybody can
get hurt in order to explain the
situation once he had to realize that
diablo is just a fellow sim the two make
peace and [ __ ] burger decides to part
ways with the group
diablo and cheera then head out to
complete their quest and when they
arrive at the bridge of
look the soldiers there seemed to be on
guard against something apparently they
had received reports of an
army with over 100 fallen that are
heading their way
the fallen were treated as boss monsters
and cross reverie but diablo has never
heard of them attacking in mass
rumors have it that the fallen are
hoping to revive the demon lord krebs
golem so they might eventually target
rem
this is enough incentive for diablo to
offer up his help in defeating the
approaching army when the army arrives
diablo is forced to stand against them
by himself because everybody else is
pretty [ __ ] useless now we jump on
over to rem who gets visited by
celestine she tells the walmart rem that
they had discharged golic from the
association because he was the one that
had targeted them with the fake quest
speak of the devil gollug then busts in
on their talk and seems to be relatively
distraught with the decision to make him
leave the association he starts to get a
bit cringe while begging celestine to
reconsider it's
like pull yourself together man the [ __ ]
is this after the two-year-old's done
throwing his
tantrum he decides to stab himself with
some creepy looking blade and he ends up
turning into a fallen named gregor
back on over to diablo who has defeated
around 30 of the fallen which prompts
the commander of the army to approach
him
edelgard is the strongest and the
thickest of the fallen so she prepares
to fight with diablo one on one
he concludes that if he can defeat her
then it's likely the battle will just
end as of the two square off in the last
scene
episode four ram and zelda scene are
forced to flee from the fallen which is
when burger bitch's simp senses start
tingling so he steps in to save them
even after realizing that he's pretty
outmatched by the fallen he still tries
his best to protect the girls like any
good
simp would meanwhile diablo is getting
his biggest challenge yet realizing that
edelgard
is level 80. as her trump card she uses
her sacrificial charge ability
this ability marks the first time that
diablo has taken
damage in this world since he had
arrived diablo then gets the
news that rem and celestine are being
targeted by a fallen so he decides that
he needs to wrap this fight up he uses
white
nova which pretty much levels everything
in front of him but conveniently leaves
the only hot fallen alive and without
clothes
so yeah deciding that there's no other
way to get back to the city in time
diablo tries teleporting magic which
ends up working getting him back to rem
the bitchin burger was the only one left
to fight and on his last legs when
diablo arrives
diablo steps in and quickly defeats the
fallen banishing him to the shadow
dimension for eternity
unlike in the game characters killed
don't come back to life so
everybody in the city who was killed by
gregor are buried three days later
more titty filler content then sylvie
comes in to tell diablo that the lord of
ultra city has received demands from the
elven kingdom
saying that shira has to be handed over
within 10 days
if the demands aren't met then war might
be declared between the two powers
sylvie gives him the quest of preventing
the war to maintain the peace
episode 5 they learn that shira has a
bounty for her return
so they can never really feel safe
anymore diablo then goes to meet with
lieutenant general chester ray galford
the leader of ultra and the one who made
the quest for diablo to prevent
war he confirms that shira isn't going
anywhere and that diablo will find
another way to prevent the war
in response to this gal fort introduces
yet another cutie chan and alicia
cristela
an imperial knight who is assigned to
help them in their task
everybody heads to a weaponsmith because
diablo wants to get a weaker weapon
wheel
it would cause problems if you
accidentally killed a person so he wants
to nerf his stats a bit while collecting
other supplies men try to abduct shira
for the bounty
the gender specific canine meat patty
steps in to aid in the rescue and the
bounty hunters are subdued
after that everybody gets ready to head
through the elves forest
and meet with shira's older brother to
prevent the war
episode 6. celestine meets with them to
tell them that she may have found a way
to remove the slave collars
and set the girls free a slave caravan
had arrived at the city so they go to
see if they can find out more about the
callers
when they arrive they meet the owner
meteos in order to ask her if she knows
a way to remove the enslavement
meteos can see people's flow of magic so
she recognizes that diablo is extremely
strong
and that rem is giving off some sort of
sinister magic
ram isn't feeling so hot after that and
is anxious that she'll be found out to
calm her down
alicia offers to use a charm that will
help conceal secrets when they're about
to be exposed
when she does there's some sort of
alarming reaction but she doesn't
mention it to rem diablo works with
shira and meteos in some perverted tests
to try and release the caller
it's a roadblock because he can't see
the flow of magic power coming from the
enslavement callers they're like threads
of yarn all tangled together and to
release the enslavement he has to
unravel
all of them piece by piece it proved to
be too difficult so they had to take a
break
while talking in their room they hear a
flu outside which cues the entrance of
shira's older brother
kira l greenwood the first prince of the
kingdom of greenwood he seems peaceful
and says that his father was worried
about shiro but they don't want to go to
war over it both parties agree to meet
the next day and let shira decide if she
wants to return or not
in the last couple of scenes kira seems
to be up to something saying that shira
his
sister will bear his child meaning that
greenwood is this world's alabama
episode seven while shira and diablo are
making potions the next day they
suddenly hear kyra's flu
shira becomes brainwashed and says that
she's going back home with kira
diablo had said before that he would
respect her decision no matter what it
was so he tells the others that he's not
going to intervene
after some reflection he decides that
they're all friends there so he can't
just let her get [ __ ] by her brother
so him rem
and alicia all go to get her back we
then hop over to shira and kira who are
still making their journey back
kira starts getting kinda rapey and uses
some slime to undress her which cues the
entrance of diablo
he uses the magic in the enslavement
caller to demand her to tell him how she
really
feels this circumvents the brainwashing
and she tells him that she wants to be
free and stay with him in ren
in response to this kira summons a force
hydra to kill diablo
episode 8 cross reverie never had a
summon like this
and it's supposed to be banned in this
world because it has the potential to
destroy the entire world the hydra is
powerful and has the ability to
regenerate but shira tells him that
there is a core
inside that moves throughout its entire
body if he can destroy it then the hydra
will be forced to return to its crystal
that wasn't really relevant information
though because he just blows the entire
thing up and puts an end to the fight
as he gets ready to kill kira shira
steps in to stop him because they're
still family so he lets the perv go
as he runs off into the forest that
doesn't last too long as galford
decapitates him and reveals he has an
invisible army with him guilford had
decided that it was
war as soon as elvish soldiers had
entered his land before diablo can do
anything he is captured inside a spell
that he doesn't recognize from the game
alicia tries to stand up to him but he
breaks her blade revealing that he's on
another level and she can't win
their plan is to take shira hostage but
diablo had managed to find the source of
the magic creating the barrier the same
way he attempted with the callers and
breaks it misleads do a little skirmish
between diablo and galford
galford is over level 120 and gives
diablo a run for his money but
ultimately loses in the end forcing them
to withdraw
in the end the only casualty was the
incestuous pervert so all in all pretty
good day
diablo is pretty drained of mp after
that so while resting
sylvie brings him some alcohol to
restore some of it he's a bit of a
lightweight so he gets wasted and groped
silvi he better pray to god there's no
me too movement in this world
episode 9. while alicia is reporting
back to the higher ups about the
greenwood incident we meet a new
character in
sadler during their talk we learned that
sadler is going to falter also
apparently the head priest lumachina
revealed a prophecy saying there are
omens of the demon lord's revival in the
western city
since he is a paladin he's going to
investigate this a classic bathing scene
gets interrupted by edelgard who comes
across them
she had heard that rem is carrying crap
skullum and by touching her she confirms
that it's true
turns out the fallen can't just kill her
to release it there's more to it in
order to summon krebs golem so elgar
doesn't want to hurt her edelgard then
agrees to teach them a summoning ritual
to bring out crept skull
since they both want the demon soul out
of rem's body they agree to meet in
three days at starfall tower where
summonings are conducted in order to
perform the ritual when they get back to
town alicia finds them she warns them
that sadler is there and that he's over
level 100 so he's just as strong or
stronger than gal ford well heading to
get somewhere safe they conveniently run
into
sadler and his men ram starts to get a
little bit lippy with him so he starts
casting a spell on her claiming it's the
power of god diablo can see that is
really just a low-level spell and when
he points this out
sadler targets him instead he uses
cement lock but diablo's ring deflects
it turning sadler to stone instead
[Music]
the spell is gonna wear off eventually
so we can expect to see him again but
for now his men carry him off before
everyone heads out to go to starfall
tower they decide to tell alicia the
truth about rem and kreps gollum
episode when they arrive at the tower
edelgard tells him that diablo needs to
pour his magic
into the demon lord to hasten the
resurrection he tries doing it through
her stomach but his power can't reach
so the natural thing to do is to finger
rem
so that he can get closer to her insides
look it's not that weird they just gotta
get the magic in there
don't make it weird it's fine i mean
it's just magic
there's nothing like this looks bad
but i i didn't know that this happened
in the show before i started covering it
but i've come too far and i've put too
much time and effort so i'm gonna cover
it anyways you're gonna [ __ ] like it
so what i'm confused about is how you
pitch this to people because i'm
guessing
somebody had to go into a room full of
suits and and just be like look
she needs the magic so this is how we're
going to do it
anyways the demon lord is summoned and
it turns out to be another little lolly
get this he has to finger her too now
i'm just [ __ ] around he doesn't have
to finger her yet but still early in the
show i mean that's the exciting part we
don't know who's getting fingered or
when
you get some finger magic and you get
some finger magic look guys i'm gonna be
honest i felt really [ __ ] weird
watching the shows like what the [ __ ] is
happening
well let's not get distracted from the
dense plot unfolding
diablo is ready for the final boss fight
but turns out she doesn't remember why
she wanted to kill the mortal races
before
isn't that [ __ ] convenient guys now
the lolly could just join up with
everybody else
they're like look you can't kill anybody
okay she's like all right i mean [ __ ] it
and then christ is averted they give her
some snacks and everybody becomes
friends but then the group is approached
by the new face in euler rex
who serves the demon lords he's the
oldest and the strongest of all of the
fallen and wants to kill everybody kreps
golem is travelling with
she asks him not to because she wants
more treats she can't have him killing
her source of treats once eulorex hears
that she just wants treats he decides
that she needs to be reincarnated again
because she's incomplete this leads to a
fight between him and diablo which he
quickly realizes he can't win because of
diablo's ring he instead targets krep's
skullen but rem jumps in and saves her
leading to them becoming closer
after taking another shot from diablo
eulerics decides to retreat since diablo
is too strong when they get back
edelgard can't go into the city because
she's a fallen so she stays behind to
wake krebs gollum's return
everybody has to dry hump diablo to
restore his mp
naturally don't think about it and then
the last couple of scenes we see that
alicia has a hidden agenda of getting
kept skullham to destroy the mortal
races
episode 11. celestine is informed about
the demon lord and she agrees not to do
anything because krep's golem isn't a
threat while walking alicia lures kreps
gullum and rem away from diablo and
shira alicia plans to restore the demon
lord's memories and completely awaken
her it's also revealed that she was
actually the one who gave golic the
sword that was disguised as gregor when
sadler comes across them alicia lies
saying that rem is a demon lord
worshiper and she rescued a little girl
from them
ram tries to fight against him but is
choked and passes out when she wakes up
her ant crab skull
had been in prison the two have a
bonding moment or whatever where rem
requests that krupp's skull
never kill anyone they arrive at a
church where sadler plans to
torture them diablo gets help from
bitchburger and sylvie where he learns
rem's location
meanwhile edelgard had just arrived
outside the city with the massive army
of fallen
so celestine has to use her barrier to
keep them out as the torture starts to
get underway krep skolam tries to
convince rem to let her intervene
when the guards go to push her away
she's revealed to be a fallen so they
attack her
in order to keep her from fighting back
ram jumps in front of the attack and is
injured she begs krebs golem not to hurt
anyone
and then sadler turns her into a
pincushion killing her this is all
part of alicia's plan because the hatred
that comes from seeing this causes
krep's golem to lose control and take on
her final boss form
she quickly kills sadler while he's
monologuing and then diablo arrives on
the scene he tells shira to take his
potions and help rem while he holds off
krep's golem
episode 12. alicia had been working with
edelgard from the beginning and
everything is going according to their
plan shira is able to heal rem but it
costs them all of their potions so
diablo doesn't have any way to regen if
he's injured diablo uses apocalypse
abyss which is a massive spell that
nearly brings down krypt's golem this
gums are down enough to realize that rem
had been saved and once she learns this
she turns back into a loli
edelgard and alicia are then targeted by
the fallen because of their failures so
they're forced to flee to the city
because krebs golem is now obviously a
liability they need some way to
guarantee the safety of everybody around
her so diablo casts an enslavement spell
on her and she officially joins the
group as they're getting ready for bed
alicia pops in and takes shira hostage
she had come to them to request that
kryptskullum heal
edelgard because she was injured while
fleeing from the fallen of course she
agrees to this and
after she's healed she agrees to follow
krep's golem's orders so they keep her
around we then learned that alicia had
to become a demon lord worshiper because
she hated self-centered greedy powerful
and entitled people that pretended to be
good with all this hatred building up
she just wanted to kill them all now
that everything had fallen through she
decides that she will just kill herself
diablo prevents the suicide everybody
forgives her so she'll be sticking
around also i'm going to be doing the
next season and you can find that on the
left side whenever i'm finished with it
or you can check out all the how to
summon a demon lord recaps in the
playlist on the right side you can also
find the links in the description below
and the only thing i hate more than
intros is outros